Steph I don't even know if you can uh
put into words what what tonight was
like for you and your teammates but take
a take a shot at it if you
[Music]
would uh it
was it was tough you know we been a very
long week for everybody in our
organization um understanding how we
wanted to you know pay honor tribute and
celebrate Dey and what he meant to our
our
family having his family here getting
the you know the celebration reception
from our fans uh it's tough looking over
at you know his
chair but uh coach challenged us to kind
of utilize all those emotions and get
lost in the game uh you know it was it
was weird at first but this is our
sanctuary and the competition like we
know Dey would love nothing more than to
see us go out there compete and have fun
as best we can and and it feels really
good to to get a win he's clearly in all
of your hearts and you guys played
inspiring basketball ton night talk to
me about your your back screens and and
your ball screens that you were setting
early in the game it seems like you
really enjoy those and it's really
unselfish of you to do that being the
Superstar you
are I mean you have to continue to try
to make adjustments on you know how
teams are guarding us as a as a group um
and you know I've seen everything so to
be able to kind of change look up a bit
you know get wigs and JK
downhill they got to make decisions and
it just changes you know the vibe a
little bit on how we try to create good
shots so been doing it since I was
Davidson I love setting screens coach
mckill out there I know he's proud Steph
Jonathan kaminga now has a shooting
record that you don't have in Warrior
history he's 11 for 11 to tie Chris
Mullen most makes without a Miss in any
War game 11 for 11 for JK that means 12
for2 for you coming up at some point n
I'll take the three for two any
day advanced analytics but that's crazy
though I didn't know that but talk about
21 straight games for JK and double
Figures it's a lot of your screens it's
a lot of things where you and you know
Clay Cross pass but kaminga is coming on
man we're starting to see he led the
team in rebounds tonight too tell us
about his development a little bit of
what you're seeing
yo obviously he's so talented he can get
to wherever he wants on the floor
whenever he's under control and sees the
picture so it's just a matter of him his
only challenge is to continue to be
aggressive picking and choosing the
spots um and you can see he's been
really selective on whether he's trying
to get all the way to the basket whether
he's in the post up and taking advantage
of matchups and getting to his mid-range
you know taking open threes if he has
them I don't know if he's shot any
tonight but it's all about just being
decisive about what he's doing and then
on the defensive end utilizing that
athleticism uh to to help our our front
Court our back court like everything so
he's he's he's taking on the challenge
you can tell he's getting so much better
and that's all you ask for I I think the
most hype you got tonight was when you
hit him for that pinpoint pass where you
thread the needle man where do you see
the replay on that step that was amazing
that was sick but how much do you enjoy
that part of your game we we talk about
the the shooting the pyrot Technics all
your handles and video game moves but
your passing ability was on display
tonight too yeah again you see a lot of
uh lot of different looks from the
defense and in that particular play
you're trying to bark out like where the
cut is and uh for us to you know take
advantage
of The Blind Side of the defense and I
told him that was a crazy catch he made
cuz I saw him for a second then I didn't
next thing though he was laying it up so
uh my celebration was more thank God it
wasn't a turnover yeah we're we're
showing it right now we're going to give
you the the right-handed pickup pass no
lefties though all right no lefties the
left my only turnover that Lefty one
over in the first half I hate that hey
thanks for stopping it's you know this
is not going to feel normal for a long
time we we know that it's kind of day by
day and you won't have much time to
think about it with the Kings coming
tomorrow man but you're our brte always
we appreciate it yes sir appreciate yall
thanks brother right that is the one and
only Stephen
Curry